one year ago today the US sanctions
against Iran over its nuclear program
where I reintroduced that means the u.s.
punish everyone who trades with Iran and
the sanctions have bitten Iran's economy
is in freefall soaring inflation has
even prompted the government to save
four zeros off the value of the currency
meanwhile many foreign companies are
pulling the plug on their operations in
Iran
once upon a time doing business in Iran
was reasonably straightforward now
foreign companies operating there are
finding themselves caught up in
political strife after 120 German firms
who had a presence in the country half
have now pulled out fearful of angering
the United States if they stay European
businesses that want to keep trading
with Iran without infringing US
sanctions can't do so by using a
specially created instrument called
insects but take-up is not widespread
and the reintroduction of US sanctions
hasn't only damaged business ties it's
all but eroded Iran's most important
source of revenue oil back in March of
2018 Iran was exporting some 2.8 million
barrels of oil a day just over a year
later the figure had halved and analysts
now say it's close to zero the
International Monetary Fund expects the
Iranian economy to shrink by 6 percent
this year the turmoil has even prompted
the government into a drastic move it's
shaved four zeros off the value of the
real in order to curb inflation could
have a bad impact on our lives it makes
me think about how valuable those zeros
once worm's it changes the value in our
minds my money is not so devalued that I
don't see it as worth much as inflation
continues to soar many Iranians are
struggling to afford basics like food
and medicine unemployment - especially
among young people is on the rise I'm
now joined from Tehran by Doc Martin
Bernstein she's with a German Iranian
chambers of commerce welcome to the show
doc my one-year on after the sack
were introduced if you compare the
business climate in Iran a year ago and
today what has changed since the new
sanctions are in place well I mean if
you look at the figures it's quite clear
what has changed so the first five
months in 2018 we had a trade volume
with Europe from around eight point five
billion euros now the first five months
in 2019 it's just around two billion
euros so it's 76 percent less than last
year
with regard to Germany it's around 50
percent less though in last year we had
1.2 billion euros crate this year it's
only 650 billion dollars so the figures
show you that there is a huge reduction
in trade very much to the regret of
European and especially German companies
in the figures they are quite clear but
what do the sanctions actually mean for
the day-to-day business of foreign
companies operating there in Iran I mean
the the day-to-day business is has
become much harder as I can say not all
German and not all European companies
have left the country and by far not all
have lost the interest in that market
though they try to stick to this market
but it has become much more complicated
and much more costly especially with
regard to the financial transfer which
is the hardest part of staying in Iran
well you mentioned the financial
transfer
difficulties there has insects has it
has that helped by any chance
I mean insects can help and will help
but insects so far is not active though
the first move has been done but not
finalized so far there are still some
technical questions to beyond answered
especially from the Iranian side so I
guess we as we have now a new head of
insects mr. Ebell who is a former
ambassador of Germany to Iran and who is
very well known here in the country I'm
looking really forward to have him here
to to make the first strike and the
first move go on
and then I guess insects will be really
a great help Dartmouth on boon stand
there thank you very much for joining us
today
welcome thank you